you're absolutely amazing more to
miracles in two days when it comes to
football so let's speak now to katie
Spencer who is just around the corner
from spur stadium in North London and
the celebrations at full voice where you
are no doubt yes things have been
getting very noisy certainly within the
last 10 minutes or so the certainly gave
Liverpool a run for their money in the
end it was a bit of a shaky start in the
first half but boy did they manage to
turn things around in the second oh you
might be able to spot behind this
they're actually sweeping up the pine
glasses because people were so
absolutely so shocked and thrills when
the final whistle went in the end of
them here is Martin one of the bad part
in a dream night then oh my god it's
beyond the tree I mean like it's at a
point where I almost tried to wake
myself up from the nightmare at halftime
and go home no it was it was terrible it
looked like I was texting all the mates
I have for a Spurs fan so I do watch it
to try and pick myself from up from it
because I knew it quite a lot my mates
are actually out there in Amsterdam and
I saw what they what they write on the
phone and they don't need to be so
picked up my site I might just go out
and put the laptop on and just watch the
second half but just try and sort of
keep it quiet one and then right now
okay now I plan on staying at poppy I'll
keep the Fife and arrives be hunts be on
shows that they will yeah well worth
that for you now of course this means
all-english final and we've just yet we
just got a beat Liverpool which there's
beating Barcelona for nil in front of
your own fans but in this going out to
Madrid and taking a real hiding of space
isn't there which is I presume what's
going to happen on the first of June so
I'm fairly confident it should be a
pretty straightforward win I'd imagine
we'll make a tramatic I've wasted would
be much worse quits with so it'll maybe
be a late one or they'll they'll get a
goal or two but basically Spurs about
this so now part of thought Cup final it
was in 2008 Manchester United vs.
Chelsea in the end Manchester United
managed to do it in extra time and
penalties will it happen again will it
be easier than that we'll have to wait
and see Jim the first